>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good afternoon,
and welcome to the
African/Middle East Division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief of the division,
and I'm happy to see you all here
for this very exciting
event with Kwame Dawes.
Today's program is
the second this fall
in the ongoing Library
series entitled Conversations
with African Poets and Writers,
and the 25th in this unique series.
In October, 2011, the
African Section
of the African/Middle East Division,
in partnership with the Poetry
and Literature Center, headed by
Rob Casper; and the African Society
of the National Summit on Africa,
then headed by Bernadette Paolo,
and now by Patricia Baine,
the present President;
and Ambassador Pamela Bridgewater,
the Chairman of the Society launched
a new program in the Library
of Congress consisting
of conversations,
interview with established and
emerging poets, short-story writers,
novelists, and playwrights of
continental and diasporic Africa.
The inspiration for that series came
from an earlier program organized
by the African Section
in November 2008
to celebrate the 50th anniversary
of Chinua Achebe's classic
"Things Fall Apart."
So here we are in 2016, and the
Conversations with African Poets
and writers is going strong.
It is well-established and
has brought to the library,
and to our patrons and
readers, as to all those
who access the library's
webcasts around the world,
some of the best poets
and writers from Africa.
The poets include Keorapetse
Kgositsile, the Poet Laureate
of South Africa; Susan Kiguli from
Uganda; Anna Mwalagho from Kenya;
Omekongo Dibanga from the
Democratic Republic of the Congo;
and Tijan Sallah from Gambia.
We've also invited award-winning
writers like Amadou Kone
from the Cote d'Ivoire;
Igoni Barret from Nigeria;
Lemn Sissay from Ethiopia, who
then became the new Chancellor
of the University of Manchester.
No connection, he was going to be
the Chancellor without our series,
but anyway, I just
wanted to mention.
And last week we hosted
Shenaz Patel,
the first Mauritian
writer in the series.
There are too many to mention,
but we are partnering with others
to bring more of these exciting
writers and poets to the awareness
of the American and the
international public.
But before we start the
program, I would like to say
that we are deeply honored to
have Kwame Dawes with us today.
He has been described as the
busiest man in literature.
So we are really privileged
to have him here,
an Emmy Award-winning poet,
actor, critic, musician,
editor, and so much more.
Let me first introduce the
President and Executive Director
of our partner organization
the African Society
of the National Summit on
Africa, Patricia Baine,
who will make some remarks
after which Robert Casper,
the head of the Poetry
and Literature Center,
who was behind inviting Kwame
Dawes, trying to convince him --
to bring him to come here.
He will introduce Kwame Dawes.
And then Dr. Angel Batiste,
Africa Area Specialist
in the African Section
of this division,
will conduct the interview.
So Patricia.
[ Applause ]
>> Patricia Baine: Good
morning again [applause].
I'm Patricia Baine.
I'm President of the Africa Society
of the National Summit on Africa,
an organization that started
out as a grassroots organization
to engage Americans about
what they would like to see
and how they would
like to shape U.S.
/Africa foreign policy.
Today the Africa Society
is the premier organization
that engages Americans about Africa
and creates partnerships to inform
about the continent's peoples, its
cultures, and its contributions.
And there's no better way to do
that than through a cultural lens,
because today we know
what influence culture has
on the perception of people.
So today we're excited for another
iteration of our conversations
with African poets and writers,
with the African Section
of the Middle East and Africa
Division and the Poetry
and Literature Center of
the Library of Congress.
Both of our organizations --
all three of these organizations are
committed to providing a platform
for African literary figures.
And it's our privilege today
to have Mr. Kwame Dawes.
I guess, if it's acceptable to call
him Ghanaian-Jamaican, I don't know.
But you have a rich cultural
background that is only rivaled
by your prolific artistic
expressions in literally everything,
poetry, novels, plays, film,
plus taking on a whole host
of social and cultural issues.
We're honored to have
you today, and we're glad
that we have a good audience to
engage in this cultural exchange.
And I will now ask Mr. Rob Casper,
head of the Poetry
and Literature Center.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Casper: Thank
you, Patricia.
I was just remarking to Patricia
and to Mary-Jane how it feels
like a family gathering whenever
we come together for this series.
It's thrilling to see the
great range of writers
from around the continent that
we've been able to feature here.
And we're thrilled and delighted
to have Kwame Dawes here today.
Before we begin that, let me ask
you to turn off your cellphones
and any other electronic devices
that you have that may interfere
with the recording of this event.
Second, there's a Q-and-A
session, and if you participate
in the Q-and-A session,
you give us --
we ask that you gives us permission
for future use of this recording.
We're recording it for webcast.
Before I tell you about
Kwame and this program,
let me tell you a little bit about
the Poetry and Literature Center.
We are home to the Poet
Laureate Consultant on Poetry,
and we put on 30 to 40 programs
like this throughout the year.
If you want to find out more
about us and programs like this
at the Library of Congress,
you can visit our website,
www.loc.gov/poetry.
You can also find out more
about events in this division
in this wonderful reading
room, and look at the webcasts
of previous Conversations
with African Poets
and Writers series events
at www.loc.gov/rr/amed.
As the two previous introductors
[sic] have said, we're thrilled
and delighted, we're honored to
have Kwame Dawes here today to close
out the fall Conversations season.
Born in Ghana in 1962, Kwame
Dawes spent most of his childhood
and early adult life in Jamaica.
He is the author of over 30
books, and his 16 collections
of poetry include "Progeny of Air,"
winner of the Ford Poetry Prize
for best first collection in
the U.K., and "Duppy Conqueror,
New and Selected Poems,"
published just a few years ago
by Copper Canyon Press.
Dawes' novels include
"She's Gone" and "Bivouac."
And his non-fiction
collections include "A Far Cry
from Plymouth Rock, a
Personal Narrative,"
and "Fugue and Other Writings."
The editor of several anthologies,
Dawes is also an actor, playwright,
and producer, an accomplished
storyteller and broadcaster,
and the lead singer in
Ujamaa, a reggae band.
Fifteen of his plays have
been produced, and in 2009,
Dawes won an Emmy for
livehopelove.com,
an interactive site based on his
Pulitzer Center project, "Hope,
Living and Loving with
AIDS in Jamaica."
Dawes' other honors include the
Hurston/Wright Legacy Award,
the Poets and Writers Barnes and
Noble Writers for Writers Award,
and a Guggenheim Foundation
Fellowship.
In 2004, he received the
Musgrave Silver Medal
for contribution to
the arts in Jamaica.
And in 2008, the Elizabeth O'Neill
Verner Governor's Award for service
to the arts in South Carolina.
In 2009, he was inducted into the
South Carolina Academy of Authors.
Kwame Dawes is currently the Glenna
Luschei Editor of Prairie Schooner
and Chancellor's Professor
of English
at the University of Nebraska.
The co-founder and
programming director
of the Calabash International
Literary Festival, he also teaches
in the Pacific MFA Writing Program,
and is on the faculty of Cave Canem.
He is also the founder of
the African Poetry Book Fund,
which promotes and advances
the development and publication
of the poetic arts through its
book series, contests, workshops,
and seminars, and through its
collaboration with publishers,
festivals, booking agents,
colleges, universities, conferences,
and all other entities
that share an interest
in the poetic arts of Africa.
And I have to say on a personal
note that we've been working
on this series, the
other co-sponsors and I,
for many number of years.
And it's so heartening to have
the opportunity to bring someone
who shares our commitment to
and vision of what literature
from the continent can do
for American audiences.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Kwame Dawes [applause].
>> Kwame Dawes: So good afternoon.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Kwame Dawes: It's
good to be here.
It's a beautiful space, and I thank
Rob for initiating this conversation
that I hope will continue through a
series of collaborations and so on.
We had a great dinner last night.
And it is always good to find people
who value language and poetry.
And as I've always said, poetry
is not the answer to everything.
I think people who see poetry as
their religion are unfortunate.
But there is a time
when a poem is needed.
And when it's needed, it's
the only thing that's needed,
and it's the only thing
that will work.
And I believe this sincerely,
and I believe this completely.
I also believe that
our art is a product
that generates this
remarkable thing called empathy.
Not only generates it, but
it trains us in empathy.
The truth is that all
acts of hatred, of racism,
of bigotry are predicated
fundamentally on a lack
of imagination and incapacity
to imagine what somebody
else is feeling.
That's the function of empathy.
It is possible to have that capacity
eroded, and in fact, destroyed,
and ultimately stopped in people
if they do not have the chance
to exercise this capacity
for empathy.
And I think in the wisdom
of our millions of ancestors
over thousands, and thousands,
and millions of years,
we understood in our bodies that
the way to do so is through art,
through music, and
through the imagination.
The more we kindle the imagination,
the greater our capacity
to hurt and damage each other.
So this is my way of
saying it's good
that they pay me to write poems.
I'm saving the world.
I'll just read a few poems, and I
look forward to the conversation
that we'll have in a minute.
You know, my story is -- I
like to think it's interesting
because it's a challenging story.
I was born in Ghana in West Africa.
I grew up there until I
was about 10 years old,
and then eventually
we moved to Jamaica.
So then I grew up also in Jamaica,
and then eventually left Jamaica
as a grown man to study in Canada.
And then I've lived in
the U.S. since 1992.
There's a way in which my
journey and the narrative
of my journey is an echo of journeys
that those before me had made.
And here I talk about the
Middle Passage, that journey,
that forced journey that brought
Africans to the New World.
But even later than that, my own
grandfather, in about the turn
of the century, about 1905,
1906, decided to work --
to take on a gig with the
Colonial Office to go to Nigeria
to work there in Nigeria.
And he went -- he worked in
Southern Nigeria in Warri.
And there he littered the place
with a bunch of children, and --
including my father who was
born actually in Nigeria.
So it turns out I'm
actually Nigerian,
which is not something I say a
lot, but when it's necessary,
because you know, Nigerians
are very powerful people.
So when it's convenient
I make the association.
They're also annoying, so that's the
other reason why I struggle with it.
But one can say the same thing
about -- decidedly about Jamaicans.
Not Ghanaians.
Ghanaians are always sweet.
So anyway, that journey was
interesting because in a sense,
he lived in Nigeria for about --
he and his family lived in Nigeria
for about 15 years, almost 20 years.
And then my father
did the same thing.
Having been born in
Nigeria, he lived in Jamaica,
grew up in Jamaica, because
when he got to Jamaica
in 1928 he was just
about two years old.
But then he went back to Ghana,
and that's how I came about,
because he married my
mother who is Ghanaian.
And they had children.
And he also lived in
Ghana for 15 years.
This idea of migrations across --
that conversations
throughout this African --
Africa and its diaspora is
built into my body and my life.
And so my whole work is about
speaking from a perspective
that recognizes an
entity called Africanness,
an entity that is Pan-African,
that is global,
that recognizes the
traces, and the dignity,
and the history of African people.
And yet, it is comfortable
in the idea of movement,
and in the idea of migration.
And so my work is about
making those connections.
It's not a crisis for me.
It's not a conflict for me.
It is not a struggle
to understand myself.
I get myself.
I understand who I am.
I know, as Bob Marley says,
where I'm coming from.
So you know, I wouldn't have to ask
you, "Who the hell do I think I am?"
I know who I am.
I'm a buffalo.
I'm going to start singing.
So my poetry reflects that, and
I'll read a few poems that do that.
But I wanted to start with
a poem for Kofi Awoonor.
Kofi Awoonor was a cousin,
related to my mother,
a dear friend of my father.
And when Kofi was killed in Kenya
several years ago during that attack
at the mall in Nairobi, I was there.
We were waiting for him to
come and do a reading, in fact,
because I had arranged for
him to come to Storymoja,
because we had just
published his book of poems,
his "New and Selected Poems."
So then we got the news
that he could not be found.
And later on that night we found out
that he had died and been killed.
It's a painful recollection,
a painful memory,
because part of it was the sort of
struggle of knowing that I was --
you know, I had asked
him to come to Nairobi.
But I took great comfort, you know,
because I know the
family quite well,
in the fact that he
wanted to be there.
And it was a chance
for me to see him again
and to actually show him
the cover of the book,
because the book hadn't
been printed --
that we showed him
the cover of the book.
And he was elated and
just felt good about it.
But I -- so I like
to being my readings
with a poem dedicated to him.
This is a little small poem --
not a poem dedicated,
a poem that he wrote.
This is a small poem
called "Counting the Years,"
and it's by Kofi Awoonor.
"As usual, as in the earlier dreams,
I come to the whistling shores,
the voice of the high-domed
crab stilled.
But a chorus remains of the
water creatures of earlier times,
of the birth time and
the dying time,
the pity when we resurrect
the travelers,
the anchorman on our singular
boat that will take us home."
Here's a poem called
"After Acceptance."
It's a poem for my father.
"Then I read the monumental
legend of her love
and grasp her wrinkled hands."
It's a quote from one of his poems.
"You were a child there from two to
introverted 10, crafting your dreams
from tattered books teacher
Dawes crammed into his shelves.
Your brother was a knight,
and your sisters princesses,
and you write verse because
you longed for friends.
Curled in the cool underpart of
the creaking house on the hill,
you battled chickens for space to
sketch the worlds in your head.
We drove there together once.
You, proud of the recollections
stirred, endeared each sharp bend
in the road with names
like Breadfruit Curve,
Star Apple Corner,
and Tamarind Arch.
Your laughter was nervous
nearing the house,
the child in you drumming a rhythm
on the sweat-slick steering wheel.
On the slack porch, you pointed
through breadfruit leaves
to the faded line of the sea and sky
where Cuba wavered
in the midday haze.
From there as a child
you learned of otherness,
worlds beyond the house
afloat in a sea of green.
From there your home became
a point from which to leap.
I walk the overgrown paths where,
fired with Arthurian legends,
you galloped, mad-child on
a wild, irreverent steed,
dizzy in the patchwork of
sunlight through the branches.
The thought of you as child
is real as the trees towering.
And staring upward, I trace
your steps, avoiding the trunks
by the pattern of leaves in the sky.
The child overwhelms
my straight-back logic,
and suddenly I am sprinting,
beating hoofbeats against my chest,
light blazing green on my face, my
shouts echoed in the tree trunks.
On the barbecue, dry
brown pimento beans roast.
The ancient chair she
sat in is there
where a rotting orange tree
leans and sheds brittle leaves.
The chair is light and fading,
sucked dry by sun and salt wind.
I can see her, bandannaed there,
sharp calico against
the hill's gray,
her wrinkled hands outstretched,
trembling, her eyes glowing.
Maybe your ghosts hover
above the house a night,
but I came at daytime,
so I'm not sure.
But teachers, you taught me much
in the lesson of your silent ways.
While there, I smelled ink, and
the dust sneezed is chalk dust.
Your world was a noble one,
you cloud of holy witnesses
who sought new worlds to
replace the chain-link silences.
Daily Bible verses etched on
your brow, missionary zeal,
and gave strength to
your upright eyes.
Now you hover above
this house that crumbles
where the wood ticks termites.
Maybe, grand ones, your
ghosts linger above the house,
meeting there, then
together swoop down,
one wind lifting a tattered
sheet's edge, one animation,
now a brilliant O, cooling
with a breath the sheen of toil
on some weary back, shifting
breadfruit leaves to a rustling
as eyes turn upward, smiling
at the cool, not at you,
not knowing that ghosts are wind.
You return morose,
having done your part
of touching the living before dawn
and getting little thanks for it.
You return to your tombs in which
you were sheltered from the swelter
of sun and the tramping of my
feet now in the gray and green.
I praise the dream of Sturge Town
and the silent homecoming it was.
I praise the songs of the ghosts
sealed in my mind's chrysalis.
I praise the constant leaves
spinning in the pure air.
I praise the hands that birthed you,
worn as they were, for they glowed,
stained red with first blood
spilled into this navel-string
where for years the ancient
red-barked trees have stood.
I praise these things freed
by your wrinkled hands."
I'll read two more poems.
That should do the trick.
This is a poem called
"African Postman."
Some years ago I was invited
by the BBC to write a piece
about Haile Selassie
to do a documentary.
It's actually for radio,
for BBC Four.
And the idea was that I would do
a documentary about his period
in exile in Bath, England.
So I was going to go
to Bath and, I guess,
talk to some people
at Bath, and so on.
And then I thought, "Well,
I should go to Ethiopia.
I mean, what's -- how do
you -- what's the point?
And you know, BBC is paying."
So I convinced them to pay
for me to go to Ethiopia.
And I did, and it was one of the
most beautiful and powerful times.
I got to talk to all kinds
of people who knew him.
And this is a poem
called "African Postman."
It's dedicated to a man
called Solomon Ephraim Woolfe.
I met him.
He was a Jamaican living
in Sheshemane.
That, you know, 500 acres of
land that Selassie had ceded
over to anybody from the diaspora
who wanted to go back to Ethiopia --
or go back to Africa to live.
And Solomon Woolfe was a Jamaican
who was one of those Rastas
that decided to take him up on it.
And I asked him some questions,
and then came the most
troubling question, which was --
my question to him was how did
it feel when Haile Selassie died,
which is not a question
you ask a Rastafarian.
So "Africa Postman."
"Son, who is that?
Is the African Postman, Daddy.
Burning Spear.
East from Addis Ababa then
south deep into the Rift Valley,
I can hear the horns trumpeting
over the flat-roofed acacia trees,
see the African women bend low
with wood heavy on their backs,
and the cows, goats, donkeys,
mules sheep, and horses snapped
into obedient herds by sprinting
children moving along the roadside.
Life happens here.
I am travelling to the land I
have heard about, Sheshemane,
the green place, 500 acres
of Jah's benevolence.
And I know now that I long to
hear the rootsman tell me how,
despite rumors of his passing,
the natty keeps on riding,
keeps on standing in the
fields of praise to hold
onto the faith of roots people.
Brother Solomon, you put the
name Ephraim on your head
and carry the face
of the true Rasta,
the face of an Ashanti warrior,
eyes deep under heavy lids,
and your skin tight as
leather, blacker than black.
I have met you before on the streets
of Kingston, there where you trod
to the hiss and slander
of the heathen.
You, natty dread, gathering
the people's broken minds
into your calabash.
You carry it all, tell
them, "Return to the roots,
the healing shall take place."
You are Burning Spear's
voice in the fields of teff.
You tell me of the prophecy of
Marcus, and I listen to you,
through the phlegm, through
the gruff of your voice.
And suddenly when I ask you
about the passing of the Emperor,
you rise up like a staff of
correction, your voice reaching back
to the mountains, your warrior
self, our yardman greatness,
and you speak a mystery of those
who have ears but won't hear,
and those who have
eyes and won't see.
And I know that this dread
will one day stand in this soil
and find his feet growing roots,
that soon the earth will be darker
for the arrival of Solomon.
Oh, let the heathen rage,
let the doubters scoff,
let this Ghanaian youth whose eyes
have seen the face of Jesus Christ,
let him, too, sit and marvel
at the faith of the natty.
For this African postman has
forsaken father and mother,
and has come to stand
before His Imperial Majesty,
to call only him father, so that
the father might call him son,
and the world will carry
on its weary march.
And the ibises will swoop
in the Ethiopian dusk,
and the smoke will rise from the
wood fires, and the night will come
with the news that the
rootsman, after 400 years
of being told he's
homeless, has come home.
Yes, Jah, has come home.
Sons and daughters of His
Imperial Majesty Haile Selassie,
Earth Rightful Ruler, without
any apology say, this is the time
when I, and I, and I, and
I should come home, yes,
Jah, oh, come a holy foe.
Nah leggo, nah leggo, nah leggo."
Okay, so I'll end with
a poem called "Rope."
I was happy to see when I went
to the African American
Museum yesterday that --
you know, I was nervous
going in because I said --
I went to the theater
section, and I said,
"I they don't feature
[inaudible] and August Wilson,
I'm burning the place down."
And I was happy to see
that they recognized.
So those two are featured.
August Wilson is the center of a
new collection of poems that comes
out this year from the
[inaudible] from me called,
"City of Bones, a Testament."
And this poem called "Rope" is a
response to August Wilson's work.
Some of the work I've done, the
academic work, the scholarly work,
is to talk about August Wilson's
engagements in African aesthetics,
the idea of diaspora,
the aesthetics,
but particularly the African
aesthetics in his work.
But his poems -- his plays are
remarkable, just an amazing thing.
So this poem is called "Rope."
I usually read the last few
lines of the poem first,
and then I'll come
back and start again.
So this is how the poem ends.
"Someday a soul will
come out of the fields
to claim it, and then we will know.
Someday a soul will
come out of the fields
to claim it, and then we will know.
To hold our lives together on
the cart before the slow march
after midnight along
backroads, blind-driving,
the scent of the exhaust
making us drowsy,
every shadow in the fields a
threat of sorts, we use rope thick
as two thumbs side by side, pulling
hard on the knot to keep our parts
from falling by the wayside.
We have kept this rope supple
with oil, constant use,
never letting it stay
idle long enough to rot.
It is hard to look at the coiled
silence of our strongest rope
and not think of what it has held,
the heavy grey-green battered
bucket knocking the stone sides
of the wall, top water
spilling back down,
this cherished substance
carrying our lives.
The mare, white and grey, plodding
across the wide open field at dusk,
her head heavy with labor, the
rope a caress against her cheek,
the way she turns toward
a gentle tug.
We hold the balance of
our need in this rope.
The dead weight of Junebug at
dawn, his skin still steaming,
his beautiful black skin
catching the morning light,
tender among the leaves, how we
found him there, his neck stretched,
the wrapping of several
yards of taut rope
around the drooping branch, where
we found it, how we undid the knot,
let his body down into
our arms, then carried it
like a soldier's flag,
bearing it behind the cart,
shaking along with his swollen body.
This ordinary rope, this
gift we cannot forget,
this remembrance of
what we have lost.
Someday a soul will
come out of the fields
to claim it, and then we will know."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Angel Batiste: Kwame,
I have a few questions.
>> Kwame Dawes: A few
questions, good.
>> Angel Batiste: And each
question has many parts.
I'd like to start with asking
you wear many hats, actor,
writer, scholar, musician.
How did you come into writing?
>> Kwame Dawes: So these days
I've been sort of rehearsing --
I've obviously answered
this question before,
and I realize sometimes
I lie in my answers.
And then the lie becomes
sort of rigid as truth.
We see a lot of that.
So these days I'm -- I've been
forced to re-examine my answers
to these questions so that I can
speak some truth in all of this.
It turns out, though, that you
know, writing is a funny thing.
There are two parts to it.
One is the motivation to do
it, to actually do the writing.
The other part is to
feel permission to do it,
the sense that it's okay to do it.
And I think some of the struggles
that most writers who are beginning
to write have is asking themselves,
"Do I have a right to do this?"
Or, "Do I have -- is it in
-- it doesn't make sense."
Wives and concerned family
members will say, "What?"
And they mean it, and
they are not wrong.
This may not necessarily
be the most --
the easiest way to eat
on a regular basis.
So there are those two questions.
And the other question
is is it in the realm
of possibility as a kind of reality?
So for the first one, I think it's
safe for me to say that I wrote
and I write because I read.
So the business of
reading gave me pleasure.
And for some -- at some point I
became interested in replicating
that sensation, and I
discovered that the pleasures
of reading can be replicated
somehow in writing.
They are not equivalent,
but they are similar.
So we grew up in Ghana, and
my father was notoriously
against television in the '60s.
So we didn't have a television.
People did, but we didn't.
And he was adamant about that.
I just think he didn't
want to buy a TV,
but he had wonderful philosophical
reasons for not buying.
You know, it's market -- he was
a Marxist, so it's capitalist,
and it's just -- it will addle
your brain, and things like that.
So -- but what he did
do is that he said,
"You can buy any book you want.
And I don't -- I won't
quarrel with that."
And so -- and this meant comics
even, like you know, Marvel comics.
Anything that you read,
he said, "That's fine."
So we just bought comics
[laughter], and he paid for it.
That's great.
But -- so we did -- we realized
that our entertainment would
have to be through reading.
And so that's what it was.
And I think soon we as kids --
there were five of us growing up --
and I think we as kids began to
-- if we ran out of books to read,
we began to play around
at writing these books.
We were not precocious
little bright kids.
We just -- you know,
we -- you know, you go,
you bully some kids,
you beat them up.
And then you come home, you
don't have anything to do,
you don't have a book to read.
You say, "Hey, let's
make up some stories."
So it's that -- we were
-- that's what we did.
Now this doesn't mean all my
family does -- my family --
I'm the only one who is a writer.
So that's -- I think
-- but that sense
that I could replicate the sensation
and the pleasures of reading
through writing started
fairly early.
And the only other thing that I
think continues to be relevant
to my impulse to writing is
that when I was about 11, 12,
maybe about 13, I discovered
this thing called pen pals.
And in those days there were
these little teen magazines
that would come, and in
those teen magazines,
at the back of them people from all
over the world would put their names
and their addresses, and you
could just write a letter to them,
and you know, you wait three --
well, you wait a month, really,
maybe a month and a half
-- it's not email --
and it will come back,
right, with a response.
And I began to do a
lot of pen pal writing.
And I became kind of drawn to it
because I think it's hard for people
who are younger to
understand that in a world
in which there is no Internet,
there is no googling of information,
I could become very quickly,
at least for the people I was
writing to, the premier authority
on everything -- not just me,
but everything Jamaican,
to be honest with you.
I gain authority because if I
said I like Ackee and saltfish,
they couldn't google
Ackee and saltfish.
So if I said Ackee tastes like
-- you know, like ice cream,
they just had to take
my word for it.
You understand what I mean.
But I was -- I became
enamored of this process.
And I wasn't trying to fake it.
I was trying to -- I found it
exciting that I could bring somebody
into my world and describe my world.
But I also was seduced by the fact
that in these letters I became
a protagonist, that I had power,
that I had a way to manage
narrative and manage experience.
If I got beat up by somebody,
even in the returning of it,
even though I was the one beat up,
I became the heroic
figure in that narrative.
And this I found deeply
seductive and very attractive.
And I can't say that that impulse
of writing for the pleasure
of making words happen for me, and
then writing with the knowledge
that somebody else is reading
it, and writing with the sense
that they will return back to me a
response to it, has ever changed.
I think that desire, that
sensation still remains at the heart
of literally everything that I
do that's pertaining to writing,
to the theater arts, to
literature, and so on.
So that's a sort of broader picture.
The step-by-step processes
would be a different thing.
But I think that's where the
impulse came from and has continued
until that -- so I'm not the guy
who says, "I write for myself."
I'm not that guy.
>> Angel Batiste: Okay.
>> Kwame Dawes: I don't
understand that guy.
I think that guy is
lying, frankly, so.
>> Angel Batiste: I'd like to go
to your work "Natural Mysticism."
In the work you construct the
concept the Reggae aesthetic.
What is the Reggae
aesthetic and how has
that influenced your
writings, your work?
>> Kwame Dawes: Yeah,
so at some point --
you know, here's an
interesting story.
Just recently I've been looking
at diaries I wrote in my 20s.
And this is one of the beauties
of me saying, "I make up stories
and think they're true," because
when you read your diary you kind
of get the facts straightened
out after --
you know, it's been 30 years
since I've read some of them.
Well, I always thought
that I started to think
about writing critically about
Reggae when I was a graduate student
in New Brunswick, which would have
been in the late '80s, '87, '88,
'89, and that this was something
that I just had started to do then.
Well, I read a -- I was
reading a diary from 1982,
and in it I had found some music
-- some Reggae music, and again,
you have to understand at the
time if you didn't have the record
or the tape, you didn't
have the music.
You had to get the actual thing.
And somebody had given me a
whole bunch of Bob Marley tapes.
Even though I grew up
listening to Bob Marley,
there were songs I didn't know that
he had done, which predated me.
And I started to -- and I
wrote about it in the diary.
I started to do this analysis
of the lyrics and so on.
And then I said, "One
of these days I'm going
to write a book about Bob Marley."
This is what I wrote in 1982.
Just, you know, that comment.
And the book, "Bob Marley,
Lyrical Genius," which came
out in the 2000s, came from that
initial impulse, which it struck me
as like shocking that I was
thinking in those lines.
But part of the reason is that when
I started to think about writing,
and when I started to think
of myself as a writer,
I wanted to understand
a kind of aesthetic
that resisted the inclination
toward a kind of slavish dependence
on Western ideologies, and Western
literature, and Western culture.
And a number of voices
began to help me to do that.
And one was Amiri Baraka
talking about Blues people.
The other was Karlamu Gya
Salaam [assumed spelling],
who has written brilliantly
about the Blues.
And the other, of course,
was Langston Hughes writing
about the Blues in "Negro
Artist and the Racial Mountain."
I became fascinated
with their try --
attempt to create a
vernacular for black poetics.
And I thought, "This is
confidence-building," because one
of the things that damages
you sometimes as a writer is
when you start asking
yourself, "Who am I?
And who are my people?
And where am I from?"
And I mean that in a literary sense.
So I thought, "This is attractive,
and this is interesting."
Then I watched Kamau Brathwaite,
who is a great Caribbean poet,
invoke jazz as a functioning
kind of aesthetic.
And I realized that he wasn't
entirely happy with that invocation
because it was borrowing something
from African American culture,
which he felt okay with, but he
was also wrestling to see what
in the Caribbean would speak to him.
So he began to develop this idea
of a kind of jazz aesthetic,
which I found very interesting.
And I started to read up on jazz.
And I thought, "This is cool.
You know, you have a
kind of folk aesthetic,
a kind of populist aesthetic
that you can then create
a poetics out of it."
And then I read Nicolas Guillen,
using sun music in Cuba to try
and explain the sort of Afrocentric
nature of his poetics, and so on.
And then, of course, I
started to look at Yeats.
And I thought, "Yeats
is interesting."
And I realized there's
a whole period
of Yeats' work which
is anti-British.
By the way, it's just the British
that you had a problem with,
not anybody else, because
[inaudible] such a big influence.
You know, Derek Walcott, divided
and [inaudible] and all that.
So say it's a big and
lasting influence.
And I found those things exciting,
so then I started to ask myself,
"What is the space --
what is the aesthetic
and emotional space
that I'm growing up in?"
And I realized that Reggae music and
all that it meant in the late '60s
and early '70s was
defining who I was.
And in fact, I began to see in poets
like Lorna Goodison, Mervyn Morris,
all these Jamaican poets,
a clear sense in which they
were being influenced by Reggae,
without admitting it, without even
saying, "This is what has happened."
So that brought me to this
scholarly idea that I want
to investigate whether there is such
a thing that one could construct
as a Reggae aesthetic through the
Aristotelian approach of saying,
"Let me look at the text
and see if I can see
in the text those aesthetic
lines that make sense."
And it began to hold
together very well for me.
And so the book, "Natural
Mysticism," became a way
in which I began to look at
whether, in fact, this phenomenon
of Reggae music with its antecedents
being, you know, Kumina and all
of these Afrocentric
music styles, was in fact,
shaping a poetics in the Caribbean.
And then I realized it was
also shaping my own poetics.
So the Reggae aesthetic
is not prescriptive.
It's descriptive.
It's actually saying,
"This is what has happened,
and I'm very interested
in seeing how it evolves"
And then recognizing
those elements in myself.
But even as it's descriptive, it's
also incredibly confidence-endowing.
It makes you feel like you are
coming from a credible space
that comes out of this wonderful
complexity of cultures mixing
and creating something, as Kamau
Brathwaite says, torn and new.
So Africa makes senses
in the Caribbean.
Africa makes sense in South Carolina
in the Gullah people and so on.
All of that begins to
make sense and works
within this musical form called
Reggae in very complex ways.
So I could -- this is one topic
I could go on and on forever
about because, of course, it
does go on and on forever, yeah.
>> Angel Batiste: I'd like
to ask one question in terms
of this concept, is this an
extension, or does it extend
into the Pan-African aesthetic?
Or is there Pan-African aesthetic.
>> Kwame Dawes: Yeah, it's
absolutely an extension.
So one of the interesting things
that I've been very fascinated
about is, for instance,
Rastafarianism.
Rastafarianism started, really,
we date it to 1938, right?
1936, '37, '38.
We can actually tell when
this new religion started.
But the thing is, so
we talk about Rasta
as this new religion
that just starts.
And Rasta's fundamental premise
is that it looks to Africa --
it presumes an important
line, shared --
given to it by gesture by
somebody like Haile Selassie.
Haile Selassie comes in and says --
you know, he takes the title
Conquering Lion of the Tribe
of Judah, takes the title that in
the -- in sort of the narrative --
the mythic narrative that he
comes from the tribe of David,
he comes from the Queen
of Sheba, and so on.
And Rastas then say,
"Okay, here's this.
This is interesting.
So we then see Haile Selassie
as the returned messiah."
So the Rastas then construct a
kind of belief system around that,
but it's a radical political belief
system, because what it's doing is
that it's proposing
that God is black.
This is problematic for
other people, but --
but the question then becomes,
"Well, why are you panicking?
I thought you said God -- doesn't
matter -- race doesn't matter?"
But when suddenly God, the returned
messiah is black and kind of hanging
out in Ethiopia, this complicates
the conversation, right?
And it's not madness at all.
It's actually a profoundly
reasonable argument
that proposes a discourse that says
those who have shown the capacity
to resist colonialism, resist
Babylon, resist the oppression
of African people,
and look attractive
and make sense ideologically as a
part of a functioning belief system.
So Rasta emerges as this entity.
And there's a long story
about how it develops.
But sometimes the mistake we make is
that Rasta just fell
down out of the sky.
But if you look at the
antecedents of Rasta,
just think of the simple Negro
spiritual, "Go down Moses,
way down in Egypt land, tell
old Pharaoh let my people go."
Built into that narrative,
that song, is a reconstruction
of Christianity, because
Moses is claiming to be --
the black people -- he -- the black
people are the children of Israel.
They're the chosen people, which
makes the white people not,
which is a radical kind of thinking.
And that radical kind of thinking is
a creative invention that is there
for resistance, as a way to resist
and a way to bring a moral authority
on the actions of those who
claim to have a kind of control
and authority over that action.
And I think there is
a way in which --
and the truth is, Jamaica's
resistance movements,
the Morant Bay rebellion and so on,
all were influenced by Baptists.
And those Baptists were
formed in the early 1800s
by African American ex-slaves who
escaped, and moved to Jamaica,
and started the Baptist
movement in Jamaica.
So this Rasta movement comes out --
this Africa is all the way through,
this notion that the
African Americans, and so on,
so forth, this is a myth.
So for me, that long
narrative begins
to make sense in that cyclical way.
And so Reggae aesthetic
does have an antecedent.
It has an antecedent that connects
with other movements that are trying
to reclaim a cultural identity
and a cultural sensibility both
politically, ideologically,
spiritually, in language, and
all these kinds of things.
And I'm not even a Rasta.
Do you understand?
But I own that.
I -- it's part of my
understanding of it, yeah.
>> Angel Batiste: Thank you.
Let's go on and talk a
bit about your new series,
"New Generation African Poets,"
which you edit with Chris Abani.
You're featuring eight new, emerging
African poets in this series?
>> Kwame Dawes: Well, the series
is an interesting project.
It's a proposal that we -- that I
came up with about three years ago.
And the proposal was that for
10 years we will publish eight
to 10 chapbooks of African poets --
new generation, poets who have not
been published in book form before.
And we do that once a year.
So we are now -- next year
we bring on the fourth one.
So we do one every year.
So we started one three year ago.
And so far we've been
doing it steadily, easily.
So this is the first one.
This was a -- this
one had seven, right.
Okay, good.
That -- you can see
them, the covers.
And this is the third
one -- or the second one.
And I think we had -- I can't call.
This is probably eight in this one.
And then more recently,
we did this one.
So this is another eight.
So this is the one that
you are referring to.
And then next year's is
going to have 10 poets.
So it's going to vary in that sense.
But these are new writers
who haven't been published,
and we do a chapbook for
each one of them each year.
And the idea is that in 10 years'
time we would have published 90
to 100 new poets from Africa.
Of the first set -- that
is the first box set --
the first and second box
set, all but a couple
of those poets have already either
have contracts for full-length book,
or they have full-length books
already published as a result
of the attention that
these works [inaudible].
Essentially we've decided
to use this mechanism
to start changing the landscape
of publishing for African poets,
and to make sure that African
poet will be published.
And this sounds like a lot,
but Africa is a big
place, you know, and stuff.
It's a big continent.
To do eight a year is like
scratching the surface.
I mean, you're barely -- we're
barely scratching the surface.
>> Angel Batiste: Is there a reason
that you chose the chapbook format?
>> Kwame Dawes: Yeah, so
we've decided to approach this
on a multipronged way,
so we're doing chapbooks,
but we're also doing a series
called "A Classic Series"
by major African poets who have
been published already, and so on
and so forth, who do not
have a collected poems
or a major new and selected poems.
And so we started with
Kofi Awoonor's book.
And that was a collected poems.
And then we followed that up
with Gabriel Okara from Nigeria,
a major -- one of the
first major poets
from Africa, who is still living.
And so we've done a
collected poems of his.
And then we are bringing out next
year Amate Alu's [assumed spelling]
collected poems.
Amate published two
collections of poems,
but had written multiple collections
of poems that were never published.
So we did the work to
pull that together.
And so her book comes out next year.
And then each year it will be --
and then the following year
Keo Pitser [assumed spelling],
who has been here before, we'll be
publishing his new and selected.
So that's one series
that we do, one a year.
And then we have a book prize
for the -- first book prize --
full-length book prize for
African poets called the Sillerman
Book Prize.
And we publish that volume.
And then we have an
over-the-transom series where poets
who may have published
before -- they're, you know,
established poets --
can send manuscripts in,
and we will, you know, publish it.
We'll arrange for them to
be published, and so on.
So it's a multi-pronged
publishing sort of effort.
Even though we -- when
I say we publish it,
what we do is we broker the
publication of these books, yeah.
>> Angel Batiste: Now with this
new generation of African poets,
what are some of the
themes, subjects?
>> Kwame Dawes: Yeah, so I think
what we -- what I've tried to do --
they -- you know, I'm an
academic and a scholar.
And my training is that way.
And so my inclination is
to do that, is to say,
"This is what is going on.
Let me write a book about
that," and so on and so forth.
But I've had to sort of resist that
as an editor, to even think about it
in those terms, because I
want the work to emerge,
and then to start speaking itself.
But of course, for each
of the box sets we have
to write an introduction.
So when I come to write the
introduction, I start to see themes.
One of the most striking
themes that I'm seeing --
first of all, the next boxed set
of the 10 poets, nine are women.
This is what has happened.
And in my introduction -- the
introduction that Chris and I wrote,
we kept returning to this idea
of the body, the female body,
the African woman's body, the
way that the body is read the way
that the body is resistant, the
way that that body is trying
to understand itself
in a changing world.
And keep in mind that
these are poets
from all different
countries in Africa.
Some are in the diaspora.
Some are living in Sweden.
Some are living in Britain.
Some are living here in America.
So they -- you see the
influence of migration.
You see the influence of a global
sensibility, the communication
that the Internet has created.
You see the influence
of them reading works
from different places, and so on.
But what is consistent all the way
through is that they self-identify
as African bodies that are
trying to negotiate what
that means in a global landscape.
I think that is a consistent theme
that we see running
through these works.
>> Angel Batiste: The
cover illustration on all
of these books are
absolutely beautiful.
>> Kwame Dawes: Yeah, you know
the story behind these, right?
So what we decided to do, for
every box set we get one artist.
We get a major African artist,
and we ask them to supply art
for each one of the covers.
So it's a single artist
for each of these box sets.
So this is a wonderful
Nigerian artist who --
so all the covers are
from his artwork.
And we have a lot of
Nigerian artists.
The first one is a Nigerian artist.
And then this year,
[inaudible] you know,
Elizabeth Alexander's husband --
late husband, who is from Somalia,
or [inaudible] originally,
he's -- she gave us his work.
So that is featured on
the cover, and so on.
So we try to create a gallery
of African art for the covers.
And I just think that's cool.
I don't know about you, but
I think that's really cool.
>> Angel Batiste: They're beautiful.
>> Kwame Dawes: Right, and
they give it to us free.
We don't have to pay for it.
That's generosity.
Now we should, but we
can't afford to pay for it.
So they -- yeah.
>> Angel Batiste: My next question
-- and it might be a bit repetitive.
>> Kwame Dawes: That's okay.
>> Angel Batiste: But
in terms of as Editor
of the African Poetry Book Fund,
what is really the history
of the organization?
What are some of the long-term
goals of the organization?
>> Kwame Dawes: Yeah, so the
African Poetry Book Fund begins
through a series of circumstances
that have to do with recognizing
and absence, a gap in thinking, that
something has to be done about it.
Chris Abani and I were touring
in Africa for the -- there's a --
Poetry Africa is a wonderful
festival that happens every year,
and they brought us there
to tour Southern Africa.
So we were visiting a few places.
And we were struck by
a couple of things.
One is there are so many
wonderful poets who were performing
and doing good work, but they
hadn't opportunity to publish.
We also saw a lot of work that
needed mentoring, needed editing,
needed some clear attention,
and they were not getting it.
And we started to make relationships
with poets to meet them,
talk to them about it, and
to talk about opportunities.
Many of them were publishing, but
didn't know where to send works
to journals and things like that.
They were rightly concerned that if
they sent it to American journals,
they would just be dismissed,
and not understood, and so on.
So we started to talk
with them about that.
So then eventually in our
conversations we thought,
"Why don't we find a way to
start publishing these works?
And to arrange to publish
these works?"
Now I have a history of
creating opportunities
for the publication of work.
In South Carolina, for
many years the University
of South Carolina Press decided
not to publish poetry again
after starting the James Dickey
series, which didn't go well.
And so they decided against it.
So I approached them,
and I wanted to --
I started an organization called
the South Carolina Poetry Initiative
to do -- to publish work and
to promote the work of poetry
in South Carolina for everybody.
And I approached them, and I said,
"Why don't you guys start publishing
poetry, because, you know,
we've got some good poets here?"
And they said, "No,
it's just a bad idea.
It's dangerous, and so on.
Nobody buys poetry, and so on."
So then I sought funding.
I looked for money, and I said,
"Look, I'll give you the money
to subvent the cost of publication
so you don't lose any money."
So that excuse goes out the window.
And they said, "Well, we don't
know where we'll find the poets."
I said, "Well, we'll find them."
And then they said, "Well, we
don't have a poetry editor."
And I said, "I will edit it.
And we'll get it edited, and
then we'll work with you,
and we'll publish these
books, and so on."
Now there is such a thing called
the Palmetto Poetry Series
in South Carolina that
is still going strong.
And that's how it started.
And we no longer have
to pay them anything,
because they've taken
it on as a methodology.
But it took several years of
them publishing these books
for it to be -- to seal it.
But essentially that's the model
that we used, talking to --
we went to many people,
many publishers.
And we were fortunate when Laura
Sillerman, the wonderful woman,
decided to support the
African Poetry Book Fund
by giving us just the money that
we needed to help subvent the cost
of publication of these books.
And that's how we made arrangements
with first [inaudible] Press,
and then later on with
University of Nebraska Press,
and of course [inaudible] Books,
and a few other places
that we are talking to.
And we do acquisition.
We do editing.
We do the mentoring of the writers.
We create a wonderful network.
So it's not just our decision,
and it's a team of people,
about eight of us who are
incredible poets, Gabeba Baderoon
from South Africa; Phillippa Yaa
de Villiers from South Africa;
John Keene, an African
American poet; Aracelis Girmay,
an African American poet
from East Africa background;
Bernardine Evaristo, who is
Nigerian heritage, lives in England,
wonderful poet; Chris Abani,
of course; and Matthew Shenoda.
This is the team, and
these are all people
who have volunteered their time
and their life to mentor writers,
work with writers,
and help us acquire.
So we have a network
all around the world.
I -- every year we say,
"Send us the name of poets
that you think should
get some attention."
We approach the poets, and
we say, "Send us some work."
So for each of these chapbooks
we get about 40 submissions.
We ask -- we request 40 submissions,
and then we select the ones
that we think are the
strongest ones.
And we continue to work with
those that we don't select.
So it's a big, major kind of
effort that the product is
in four years we've published
over 40 poets -- African poets.
>> Angel Batiste: Now you're also
editor with "Prairie Schooner."
>> Kwame Dawes: Yes.
>> Angel Batiste: So can
you discuss that a bit?
>> Kwame Dawes: Yes, so
"Prairie Schooner" is a --
I don't know if you know this, but
it's probably one of the oldest --
it's the third oldest literary
journal in this country, right?
"Prairie Schooner"
began in the early '20s.
It's been going for 90 years.
And I joined -- I became the
editor about five years ago.
Before that it had been run by
Hilda Raz -- the amazing Hilda Raz,
who had run it for about 30 years.
I think that I'm the fifth
editor of this journal.
So it's one of these
-- and they never --
this is 90 years of continued
publication, a quarterly.
This is remarkable because
Depression, wars, whatever,
they've been publishing steadily.
So becoming the editor of "Prairie
Schooner" was very exciting,
but of course, when I came in,
"Prairie Schooner" had one --
"Prairie Schooner" made the hugest
difference in terms of women poets,
women writers in the '80s and '90s.
Hilderaz [assumed spelling] was
a great advocate and made space
for women's writing, where, very
often, most of the other journals,
which were run by dudes, were
not doing that kind of work.
And some of our great poets
today, who we know by name,
have a lot of their beginnings
with Prairie Schooner.
But when I came in, I
thought, well, okay.
We'll continue that wonderful
work and that has continued
and we have a wonderful
record in that regard.
But I wanted to make
it more international
and to extend the international
weight of the journal,
and that's what we've done.
So in a few years, the journal
has a great international reach,
but we continue to publish
this journal every year.
And also, the good news is that
Prairie Schooner gives me a platform
to do this kind of work,
whether it's work here,
whether it's in England, in
the Caribbean, with writers.
For some useful reasons, people
want to publish in a journal
so they are nice to you
when you talk to them.
So Prairie Schooner is my --
is a calling card for me
and I don't apologize.
It's been very helpful.
Yeah.
>> Angel Batiste: Working with both,
working with the African Poetry Fan
and Prairie Schooner, how do you see
African poetry and American poetry?
Is there a contrast?
Are their comparisons?
Is there something that
can be lent to each other?
>> Kwame Dawes: I think
that's a good question,
but you know what,
here's the problem.
I think -- I have to say that is a
profound compromise that I'm doing
when I say things like
African poetry.
Because in a sense,
that's a bit of misnomer.
It's a convenience.
It's a convenience
because of colonialism.
because we totalize Africa
as if it's one place.
And we do it because it's the
only way people understand.
If I said it's Nigerian
poetry, with a population
of almost 200 million
people, people will say, well,
that's a little parochial.
You understand what I mean?
So there's a way in which we
have to speak in a language
that people will understand
to get the thing done.
So comparing African poetry with
American poetry is a bit wonky.
The reason I say that is American
poetry is more homogenous,
even though it's complex and varied.
But if you think about all the
thousands of language groups
in Africa, all the
different tribes in Africa,
all the different literal nations in
Africa, to collect them as one thing
and say one thing about
it is, I think --
it's actually misleading and
intellectually problematic.
Which is why when people ask me
let's talk about African poetry,
I'm resistant of sort of
making broad generalizations
because I think it
perpetuates this myth
that African poetry is one
thing or looks like one thing,
in the very same way that,
frankly, if you were honest
and somebody said, "Tell us about
American poetry," you would go,
"I don't know what the
heck you're talking about."
Like, how do you put somebody --
Billy Collins behind Ameri Baraka?
I mean, what connects them?
And all we do is run to Walt
Whitman and Emily Dickinson
and say that's the root
and that's all we can do.
You understand?
And everybody does this, as if this
is the only answer to that question.
So that's one kind of the answer.
But the other part of the answer
is to say that America has grown
and its poetry has grown and
blossomed because of its openness
to poetry from other
parts of the world.
And that openness has come through
publication and through translation
and through communication.
And that's why us doing this
with African poetry
enriches American poetry.
It gives America access
to the poetics of a place
that it has ignored for so
long, sometimes not willfully
because there's just not
enough books for them to look
at to see what the connections
are and to create a conversation.
So indeed, I think it
enriches the American --
because it challenges
American poetry.
It challenges American
poetry about what is poetry.
Is poetry about simply, you know,
talking about flowers and plants
or can poetry be about politics
or about spirits and
so on and so forth?
Whatever it is that is brought
into that conversation I think
enriches that conversation.
And I think the good
news about America is
that American poetry has been
open to those conversations
and we don't want those
doors to shut.
And so, we want to ensure that
that conversation continues
and that becomes --
that we become a place
in which the world's poetry
can be articulated and spoken.
Now, I might be saying that just
because I'm here in American,
because probably if
I was in England,
I would say the British
tradition has been very open.
No. But I think it's true.
I think it's uniquely
true about America.
I don't think that's
an invention at all.
>> Angel Batiste: I thank you.
Kwame, I thank you
for this conversation.
>> Kwame Dawes: Thank
you for these questions.
>> Angel Batiste: Okay.
>> Kwame Dawes: Good.
>> Angel Batiste: I think at this
point, we can have our Q and A.
>> We're just going to
put up the questions here.
So I'll come around to you
and if you have a question,
[inaudible] answer.
>> Hi. Thank you so much.
I thoroughly enjoyed it.
I wish you could stay
longer and put some more.
I so enjoyed it.
I have a quick question.
Is it okay, then, to
say conversations
with African poets [inaudible]?
>> Kwame Dawes: If
it's okay to say it?
Yes, I think it's okay to say it.
Yeah. And, I mean, as
long as we recognize --
you know, we always should put
before sort of a kind of preface
to say that we -- you know,
because you could say --
we could say English poets, we
could say poets writing in English.
We could do totalizing things as
long as we recognize that behind
that is great variety and -- as
long as we are conscious of that
and we keep saying it's not
a country, it's a continent.
It's not a country,
it's a continent.
But absolutely.
I think it's fair to say that.
And also, let's not make
any mistake about it.
The fact of colonialism has
made these countries connected
to each other, whether
they want it to or not.
And therefore, it's part
of their narrative history
and we should recognize
that and value that.
You can't talk about Latin America
without understanding Simon Bolivar,
and that has made Latin America a
thing, which it wasn't necessarily.
So -- until that political
vision of Simon Bolivar.
So I think it's fair to say that,
but also to recognize the
distinctions and the differences.
Yeah.
>> And we have to add to
[inaudible] also specific
about each country,
each [inaudible].
>> Kwame Dawes: Absolutely.
And if you don't, they will
tell you what about us?
Why do you have so many Nigerians?
Yes?
>> I just have a quick question
about language and in particular
with regards to African
languages, evocation of things
in the original language.
>> Kwame Dawes: Yes.
>> What sort of initiatives are you
doing, perhaps, or are being done
to preserve language to promulgate
poetry in the original language?
>> Kwame Dawes: Yeah.
So we are doing nothing
in terms of --
we are doing nothing
directly to promulgate writing
in the original languages
and publication
in the original languages.
But what we are trying
to do is to -- we --
one of the things that we've talked
about as a really important
philosophical question is that --
is the question of how
does a language survive?
And a language survives,
weirdly enough,
through the process of translation.
Translation actually
allows a language to survive
because if the culture
produces a work --
I mean, this is something
that I think Ngugi wa Thiong'o
was always arguing about, Gikuyu.
In 1986, when I met
Ngugi wa Thiong'o,
that was when he had decided that
he was no longer going to write
in English and everything he was
going to write was going to be
in Gikuyu and it's
going to be translated.
At the time, Ngugi was clear
about this and felt this is going
to be important and so on.
Well, it became very clear
quickly to him and to all of us
that if somebody didn't
get that work translated,
then this project was going
to suffer at some point,
and Ngugi recognized that.
And so, his last novels, whether
it's Matigari and Devil --
the lastest one, the crow
one, I forget the name of it,
all were written originally
in Gikuyu and then translated.
But you can see that when he
started his first set of books,
which were written in English,
were published at a rapid pace.
As soon as he took on this new
mandate, publication slowed down.
Right? And it's not
that he stopped writing.
So one of the ways in which
we think we've been working is
to first translate work into --
we're working with an
English audience to start off.
So we translate work from other
European languages in Africa
into English, but we also
translate in Swahili.
We've started a partnership
with the Swahili Book Prize
and if the winner is a poet, then
we will publish the translation
of that work, which
will then draw attention
to the Swahili language poets.
We are also doing -- talk about
translation of work in Shona
and different languages so
that when the books come out,
the conversation would be about
this was in the original language.
So our role, I think, is -- at least
as it stands now, with the limits
that we have, as it stands now,
is to at least create a situation
where those language
groups and the poets writing
in those languages have a life
beyond their language groups
and their communities
and have a life beyond
that through translation.
And I think that's
an important thing.
The other things is that I also
know that there's a lot of work
in those countries, more
work in those countries,
in preserving those language group
publications than, for instance,
in just publishing poets.
They would publish a language group
work rather than just publish a poet
for the sake of publishing a poet.
And this is true in India as well.
I mean, if you -- one
of the fantastic things
about India is they're such
a wide publishing world
in the different Indian languages
that has created a great thing.
But of course, their
survival, as they say,
always is if the work
is not translated,
we don't get the attention
and so on.
So we limit -- we are limited.
We intentionally limit what we can
do to make sure things can be done.
And so, one of the things that
we want to do is pay attention
to translation as a
big part of our work.
Yeah.
>> My name is William [inaudible].
>> Kwame Dawes: Yes.
>> And I'm from Guyana, too.
I'm from [inaudible].
In this -- with the question
she asked, I want to find
out if you think it would be proper
to answer the points in your --
that [inaudible] about --
>> Kwame Dawes: About
-- that's right.
>> Into English.
Because as a child, I think
my mother read me [inaudible]
over and over again.
I think [inaudible] --
>> Kwame Dawes: Oh,
it would be fantastic.
But, you know, [inaudible]
did a lot of --
[inaudible] and Anita Hoe
[assumed spelling] have done a lot
of translation from
[inaudible] into English.
So they -- so we're looking
at some of their work.
Some of [inaudible]'s poems are
translated from [inaudible].
So -- and it's true.
There's a long tradition
of that and in the north,
there are all the proverbs,
which are --
there's a fantastic process of
women taking traditional proverbs
and making them feminist.
This is -- these women
haven't had any encounter
with Betty [inaudible]
or anybody like that.
But they are actually creating this
resistance through this rewriting
of proverbs that have been
historically men's problems.
There's a woman called [inaudible]
who is a professor in Leguan
who is doing work on that project.
So -- and we see that as part
of a larger poetics agenda
that we are interested in look at.
So that -- it's absolutely something
that should be done, has been done,
but we would love to
publish more of that work.
Yeah. We can do one more?
Yes. Hello.
>> Question about your own work.
>> Kwame Dawes: Yes.
>> After growing up in the Caribbean
and Africa, living for a long time
in South Carolina, which has a real
rich African-American culture --
>> Kwame Dawes: Absolutely.
>> Kwame Dawes: -- then,
you moved to Nebraska.
Don't want to stereotype the farm
belt, but it's a very different kind
of place and I wonder how
that's influenced your work
and your perspective.
>> Kwame Dawes: It's a
very different place.
Yeah. You know, here's the thing.
I've moved so much.
I've moved enough, anyway, and lived
in enough places, not as many --
as much as other people, I
really believe that the --
that as a poet, I have to understand
my body in any place that I live in
and there are things that
my body carries with it.
And it will emerge in my poetry,
but even as I live in that space,
my body collects this --
the details of that space.
So there is a kind of kumbaya sense
of all humanity is one
and so on and so forth.
But the truth is I can't
shake my own discourse
and my own narrative history.
So what has to happen is as much
as I might evolve or change,
Nebraska is going to
have to accommodate me.
Do you understand?
So Nebraska changes by my presence.
This is how I believe it works.
This is how I believe it
worked in South Carolina.
worked in New Brunswick.
This is -- I believe my
body changes the space
and they are going to
have to deal with it.
So Nebraska cannot be
comfortably just called a farm belt
because there's a guy who is
there who is writing in that space
who is not deciding to run away
from the reality of being there.
So I think that's how
the world's changed.
I think that's how cultures begin
to evolve, not simply by them sort
of creating what is rigidly there,
but when you bring something
into that space, it
changes that space.
That space, in changing and
accommodating becomes a new space
and an interesting space.
So there's a history
of Africans in Nebraska
and how do we deal with that?
I'll say this very short story.
In South Carolina, I became
very quickly African-American,
and comfortably so.
And in fact, I was fast -- I
was more South Carolinian --
I became South Carolinian
before I became American.
I comfortably was embraced
by the black community there
and I was an African-American.
I get to Nebraska and I'm
suddenly, for the first time
in years, Guyanean again.
Why? Because Nebraska
doesn't have a narrative
around African-American identity
except in an alien sort of way.
And I found that fascinating,
how quickly the space decides
to locate you by what it's
comfortable with and how you have
to assert that solidarity and
that connection even among
African-Americans in that space.
And I am an annoying
person so I assert it.
You know, that's my job.
Right? And my poetry is the way
that I say I'm talking to you.
Right? You know, Bob
Marley sings, "It's you.
It's you I'm talking to.
Yes, it's you.
You I'm talking to.
Why do you look so sad and forsaken?
When one door is closed,
many more is open."
It's you I'm talking to.
So if I'm in Nebraska,
people, I'm talking to you.
So deal with it.
>> Okay. One question
to close it out.
You began your reading
talking about imagination
and the importance of imagination.
But then, you also made reference to
an Africanness and the critical --
how it's important to you.
I'm interested in the
intersection of the two,
if your Africanness somehow
allows imagination for you
or if they're connected or if not.
>> Kwame Dawes: Yeah.
So I think my Africanness
or the complication
of my Africanness has
forced me to invent
through the imagination a
line of connection and a line
of identity that gives me grounding.
And invention is not that something.
Invention is pulling together facts
and experiences that
create a narrative.
That's what I mean by invention.
Right? So one of my
mottos -- and I'm --
I've been waiting for
somebody to come and knock me
in the head and say I made that up.
But I've had this for about 30
years, that all memory is fiction.
And by that, I don't mean all
memory is made up or false,
but all memory is constructed.
All memory is constructed.
We remember what we need to
remember and we create a narrative
of ourselves by constructing it.
And therefore, all that
memory is invented.
And so, the truth about Africa --
I mean, one of the
great things about going
to that museum yesterday
is just in that little hall
where you're hearing these voices
moving around so on, it almost --
it brought me to tears
because invention is survival.
The capacity to create, to imagine
a tomorrow, this is survival.
And it's been true about
African-Americans in --
and it's true about people
of African descent
for a very long time.
Now, it may be true about
everybody else, but, boy,
it's funky with African people.
It really is kind of
sweet with African people.
And that invention, I
take great solace in.
I take great comfort in and
I take a sense that I belong.
I can speak.
I have a right to speak
in this space.
And don't underestimate how
important that confidence
to say I have a right
to speak in this space.
I'll end with one little anecdote.
I remember I was in
England some years ago.
I was going to read at
Cambridge University.
And if you have been colonized
or lived in a colonial place,
you know when you say Oxford and
Cambridge, you know, it's, like,
gods and people like
that live there.
That's the notion.
Right? And I'm going, I
don't care about that.
I'm a [inaudible].
I fight against all
that Babylon business.
And I'm talking -- I had that
confidence until I got to Cambridge
and I'm sailing on their
little boats and then I --
that somebody says, you know,
Robert Burns stayed in that room
and this one stayed
-- and I got panicky
because I said what the
heck am I doing here?
This little kid, what am I doing in
the Pythagoras room, which is, like,
2,000 years old, and I'm
going to read my poetry,
my little dead poetry,
to these ancient places.
I got freaked out.
I started to panic.
And then, while we are sailing
into -- bringing this boat into t--
he bunting, it's so cliche.
But we're coming in
and we're getting in.
I hear a sound that I
go this sounds familiar.
And then, I realized
it's Bob Marley's voice.
There's Bob Marley music playing
and I'm on this river in Cambridge
and wafting through
the air is Bob Marley.
And I just thought,
well, if Bob is here
and he's not giving a
damn, then I'm good.
Then I'm good.
And that confidence
is not a small thing.
Because we have been
denied that confidence
as a people again and
again and again.
This work we are doing is
to bring that confidence
by saying there is a history,
there is a tradition, there is --
it comes from somewhere and it's
somewhere that we should embrace
and be proud of because we
need to have that confidence.
A lot of people take that for
granted, but it's a big deal
to have the confidence to say
I'm going to write in this space
and I belong in that conversation.
So that's it.
>> Angel Batiste: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.